so we have an interesting equation here
and let's see if we can solve for K and
we're going to assume that M is greater
than zero like always pause the video
try it out on your own and then then I
will do it with you all right let's
let's work on this a little bit so you
could imagine that the key to this is to
simplify it using our knowledge of
exponent properties and there's a couple
of ways to think about it first we could
look at this rational expression here M
to the 7/9 power divided by M to the 1/3
power and the key realization here is
that if I have if I have X to the a over
X to the B then this is going to be
equal to X to the a minus B power it
actually comes straight out of the
notion that X to the a over X to the B X
to the a over X to the B is the same
thing as X to the a times 1 over X to
the B which is the same thing as X to
the a times 1 over X to the B that's the
same thing as X to the negative B which
is going to be the same thing as if I
have a base to 1 exponent times the same
base to another exponent that's the same
thing as that base to the sum of the
exponents a plus negative B which is
just going to be a minus B so we got to
the same place so we can rewrite this as
so we can rewrite this part as being
equal to M to the 7/9 power minus 1/3
power is equal to is equal to M to the K
over 9 and I think you see where this is
going what is seven ninths minus 1/3
well one-third is the same thing we've
won have a common denominator one-third
is the same thing as three nights so I
can rewrite this as three nights so
seven ninths minus three nine is going
to be four ninths
so this is the same thing as M to the M
to the 4/9 power is going to be equal to
M to the K nights power so four ninths
must be the same thing
as k nights so we can say 4/9 is equal
to K nights four over nine is equal to K
over nine which tells us that K must be
equal to four and we're all done